i wanted to see the turning point when
our faces fell apart on a mass
scale i wanted to do this to really get
my head
around this subject and in order to do
this i needed to get my hands on some
skulls
old ones and lots of them i called some
friends at a foundation
which shall remain nameless the
longmouth foundation
and one of them told me my best chance
of stumbling
upon a large trove of centuries-old
skulls
was to fly to paris and crawl 60 feet
below
the garden of luxembourg down there
within
170 miles of old limestone quarries
was one of the largest graveyards on
earth
six million skeletons dating back from a
couple thousand years
to a couple hundred years so i arrived
in paris and was put in contact
with some freelance urban explorers they
were three women in pantsuits and they
called themselves cataphiles
they'd spent years mapping out the
underground passageways
and claimed to know the location of an
ancient ossuary
filled with a few thousand victims of a
cholera epidemic
that ravaged paris in 1832
this was the time in western history
when small mouths
crooked teeth and obstructed airways
became the norm
throughout paris and much of
industrialized europe
these cataphiles had spent countless
days and nights exploring
where there were no tourists no
descriptive plaques no ropes
no lights and no rules where nothing was
off limits
to be clear this wasn't the most legal
thing i've ever done
after an hour of climbing and digging
through caves and hallways
we reached an enormous pile of fibulas
ribs
and jaws bones all of them human
and skulls hundreds and hundreds of them
i'll admit
i was very much a novice and inspecting
skeletons but there really was
a clear difference in the shape and
symmetry of these skulls from the 1800s
compared to the hunter gatherers in
other ancient
indigenous populations i'd seen before
these were the patient
zeros the modern obstructive face